the pandemic's head over we're in the
sub-variant of a variant okay that
basically if you get this if as long as
you don't have underlying conditions
leukemia or uh asthma if you get this
sub-variant
that you might get a cold almost
everyone's asymptomatic if you don't
live in shanghai you walk right through
it in the past when you have a cold you
didn't destroy your life sit at home for
a week not go on planes or wear a mask
but in this environment with people
dying to hold on to the pandemic a
little bit longer it looks as though
colleges in this area
people indoors in philadelphia and for
people on trains mass transit and planes
for at least another couple of weeks
what were masks yeah the cdc it was
supposed to end in what two or three
days and the cdc has said we're going to
extend it for can't make our own
decisions for two years i had it on my
calendar for 15 more days when i when
you could fly without a mask can we also
add that it doesn't work that the
studies that show they aren't effective
ceos of all the airlines said they have
been begging with the cdc please let us
not wear masks anymore they circulate
new air in like three seconds inside
airplanes exactly right the ceos have
all said please get rid of this
yet here it is extended for 15 days some
people are for it though oh i think
there's one i think you might refer to
one uh if you watch the view one of the
co-hosts there declared professed
her desire her love
for the holy mask watch
when it comes to mass mandates
um they're there because people just
aren't great people um and that that's
just the bottom line americans just
aren't great to each other we just
aren't and so when it comes to things
like flying yeah the mandate is supposed
to be lifted april 18th i don't want to
get on a plane with super spreaders i
don't want to get on a plane with 214
other people that are going to be
breathing on me with their coveted
breath i don't want it yeah i don't want
it i want the mask i think that we
relied upon personal responsibility and
people were irresponsible
leading to the mandates right we want
people to be better than they are
and and that's just the bottom line we
cannot necessarily rely on on people to
protect their fellow man
here's what we i mean when we were
listening to that sound bite we're all
saying if she wants to wear a mask wear
it if you feel more comfortable with the
mask that's all they sleep in it if you
want a few days ago fouchy was saying
that remember he flipped and he said
make your own decisions
well uh anthony factory flips uh every
day and doesn't acknowledge it so i find
it fascinating that people are still
booking him uh we've shut you off uh
people even if you wanted to listen to
anything anthony fought she says he
contradicts himself in the next sentence
or the next appearance uh and i think he
said a few uh if you are
unsettled to whatever you have it or you
have lingering covet wear your own mask
let us make our own decisions we're done
with this we're finished we're through
stop holding on to it better yet you'll
pay at the you'll pay at the ballot box
because the american people are done
with that how about this you're through
with it if she's not through with it or
other americans want to wear your mouse
wear it make your own decisions it's a
psychosis and i feel like the the most
dangerous pre-existing condition you
could have for the psychosis is if you
had trump derangement syndrome at one
point you're very likely to be deranged
by the masks and let me just uh offer
something that i don't think is a
dispute if donald trump had won
reelection uh the democrats be like i'm
not wearing a mask they'll be saying
donald trump's warp speed vaccine
doesn't work because you guys absolutely
oh you got four you have two boosters
for jen saki and she's double backs and
she got it again they'd be saying donald
trump's vaccine doesn't work you're
exactly right it would be totally
inverse
uh what we're saying is make your own
decisions that's exactly right i'm steve
ducey i'm brian killman and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis